معنا الان من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس ارحب بك اذا ضغوط يمارسها
الرئيس الامريكي على الجانبين الفلسطيني
وايضا الاقليمي وايضا الاسرائيلي كيف ينظر
الى ذلك في
تلابي بالفعل كذلك واضح بان الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن عندما
وصل الى اسرائيل في الايام الماضيه حاول
ان يضغط باتجاهات عده لا سما في مساله
ادخال المعونات الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه و
كما قالت بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بان هذه الزياره كشفت عمق الازمه الموجوده
بين الاداره الامريكيه واسرائيل في
التعاطي مع هذه المساله وتصريحات الرئيس
الامريكي الاخيره اكدتها بطبيعه الحال لكن
من ناحيه اخرى سفيان علينا ان لا ننسى انه
على مدار اربعه شهور الاداره الامريكيه هي
التي زودت اسرائيل بالسلاح وبالع تد عبر
ايه ال الشاحنات شاحنات الاسلحه التي جاءت
او شحنات الاسلحه التي جاءت عبر البحر
وعبر ال الطائرات وبالم وهي التي دعمت
اسرائيل ايضا في المحافل الدوليه من خلال
الفيتو وما الى ذلك لكن واضح بان الاداره
الامريكيه كانت كما يبدو تعول على اسرائيل
ان تنهي حربها على غزه في غضون هذا في
غضون الشهر الفائت في منتصفه او في نهايته
وواضح بان الحرب على غزه بدات تؤثر ربما
ايضا على الداخل الامريكي تحديدا حمله
رئيس بايدن انتخابيه في السباق على
الرئاسه ولذلك ربما هذه تكون الاسباب التي
دفعت الرئيس الامريكي للحديث بهذا الشكل
وكذلك ايضا المسؤولين الامريكيين الاخرين
بما فيهم ايضا وزير الخارجيه انتوني
بلينكن الذي عندما اجتمع حتى مع عائلات
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل
قطاع غزه فهم منهم بانه يبدو متعاطفا مع
قضيتهم اكثر من رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي ابدى كما يبدو عنتا في مساله
قبول رد حماس على صفقه جديده لتبادل
الاسرى ومن ناحيه اخرى نحن نرى بان
الرساله التي بعثت بها عائلات الاسرى الى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومطالبتها ايضا بعقد
اجتماع عاجل للوقوف على الموقف الاسرائيلي
فيما يتعلق بالمقترحات الجديده بشان
الصفقه تشير الى ان ال عائلات في قلق كبير
وهي تعيش حاله من الغضب ازاء اداره
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو لهذه
المساله وقضيه الصفقه لاعتبارين الاول ان
هنالك شعور لدى عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين بان بنيامين نتنياهو يتعنت
في اتمام الصفقه لاسباب سياسيه تخصه وتخص
حكومته اليمينيه المتطرفه وارضاء للجناح
الاكثر تطرفا فيه المتمثل بوزير الماليه
بتسل ايس مترش و وزير الامن القومي تمر بن
كفير و من ناحيه اخرى هم يريدون ان يفهموا
لماذا رفضت الحكومه الاسرائيليه افاده
بعثه او وفد اسرائيلي الى القاهره من
اجل المباحثات او منجل من اجل التفاوض حول
صفقه جديده وهنالك مخاوف لدى عائلات
الاسرى من ان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وبعض الوزراء اليمينيين واعضاء
الكنيست اليمينيين هم من يقودون حمله
مضاده ضد هذه العائلات ونحن راينا بوادر
لها بالامس عندما انطلق الاف ال يمين في
اسرائيل في مظاهره تدعم الحرب وتدعم
استئناف الحرب وكانها كانت هذه المظاهره
موجهه ضد عائلات الاسرى التي تطالب بوقف
الحرب والجنوح نحو طاوله المفاوضات من اجل
اتمام صفقه جديده للافراج عن الاسرى في
داخل قطاع غز اشكرك من تلابيب مراسلنا
الياس كرام